klickt man kann auch ganz schön
ungemütlich werden
ok ok hand auf und beginnt ja die roten
ecke raus da nicht zimperlich sein
du musst es laut vorlesen
seine texte sind für viele leute schwer
verständnis willst du mit deiner
schlechten aussprache keine schlechte
text überspielen
anscheinend kann es doch deutsch schnell
lesen war die frage deine texte vielen
schwer verständlich willst du mit deiner
schlechten aussprache deine schlechten
text über spielen war butter bei die
fische dann kann ich deine texte reimen
sich nicht unbedingt und trotzdem runter
was machen sie rund was zur ruhe nach
der flohmarkt rund und was viele nicht
wissen das ich weiß schon vorher mache
immer deutsch fast alle gleich alle
machen barbara bla bla bla bla war dabei
mir ich fange an
er kommt also der letzte war und vorher
also nach dem ersten nach dem letzten
mal kommt schon direkt ein wenig fleisch
und rege ja zum beispiel keine ahnung
blablabla auto und dann tot
die reime um deswegen im letzten satz
der danach kommen also das letzte wort
was danach kommt warnte post vielleicht
nicht auf das letzte hoch von vorher
aber da ich schon vorher den reim
gemacht hab ja wundert sich dass ab in
sachen wissen ja alle gar nicht aber
auch scheißegal als schon gerne schnell
überreden weil deutsche web sowie so
lächerlich seine texte sind größter
deutschbein halt meine texte sind
größtenteils größtenteils deutsch
beinhalten aber beinhalten aber auch
viele begriffe und sätze aus anderen
sprachen
sprichst du schlecht deutsch um seine
texte kompletten leute zu stellen
schreibt die texte so wie ich rede ich
spiele jetzt zwar mit deutlich mit till
und abtreten
in deutschland redet er nicht als
typisch da kommen alle hallen dann kommt
steht noch ein paar jugoslawische wörter
arabische marokkanische kurdische tätig
gewesen kommt manchmal paar libanesische
wörter nicht von ihm gelernt habe und
ich mache einfach das war sportlich
nicht passt krieg der schalter im
interview texten gerne was du hast bist
du nicht ein bisschen abgehoben
ach das war wegen den schalen letzten
jahr da kommen auf den champagner also
besser zu trinken jetzt keinen
champagner weiter musik okay ist das
macht sich dann auch reifer als reifer
das walfleisch und schrauben klopft
das ist gefällt gewesen sich ja ja das
was ihr im interview erzählst du
meistens von alkoholreichen portisch
müssen nicht allein singen gesundes
lebens den er halt habe ich gemacht habe
jetzt alles ruhiger hören dass alles
cool
jetzt kommen die netten wagen
welche frage dabei der nicht stellen
ganzen fragen aus der deine fans
bezeichnen sich selber als zum tragen
deine klamotten wirtschaft ist mein
bester seine fans bezeichnet sich selber
als lax und tragen deine klamotten wie
schafft es eine solche bewegung ins
leben zu rufen
die bewegung hat noch gar nicht
angefangen wir sind immer noch am plan
also bei vielen dank bewegung ist hat
noch nicht angefangen als erwartet ab
lesen sie hier nach dem empfang hat aber
es wird noch viel krasser alter noch
viel krasser war laut wikipedia hast du
keinen anerkannten schulabschluss süßen
an so wenig aus so wenig aus zu wenig so
viel zu machen als es leute die
studieren und
vom leben nichts wissen hatte und ich
denke mit leute beurteilen ist weil ich
kein abschluss habe und sagen er kann
man nicht gut treppen da hat keinen
schulabschluss einfach wird die mich
verarschen was ist deutscher rap so
scheiße muss man einen schulabschluss
haben das nur rap musik macht oder was
ihr seid doch echte deutsche recht auf
schwanz als ich sagte ja es ist einfach
nur lächerlich
die ganzen leute dass kein
schulabschluss haben
aber wenn wenn du meinst das deutsche
rapper scheiße ist trotz graben eigenen
sprache alt aber wie gesagt so viele
gibt so viele gute rapper gibt heute
sachen so ja aber da gibt es auch schon
länger aber keine ahnung also die ich
meinen die fans und wie sie alles
auffassen und keine anwalt die lage ist
sie ich habe dein letztes mixtape
gekauft welches nicht in deinem neuen
schwierig man spiegel wirft jetzt auch
sehr zielstrebig seine vielfältigkeit
das hat es schon immer da ich mach das
worauf stadt münster macht worauf sie
lust habt da bin ich mal sagen würden
aber auf jeden fall schon mal ein lob
vor schluss zu warten und sieht sehr
lecker aus muss man sagen hier im
internet im winter kritisieren einige
leute wie zum beispiel julians blog
deine texte und dein rap-szene ligist
mit solchen kritiken wie gesagt
der einzige der zehn bis sind über mein
rücken mit geld verdient juli hat sich
seine ganze scheiße mit einem bleiben
mit meinem halb aufgebaut und die
abonnenten werden diese fähigkeit 100
prozent auf alter okay schau mal was
meinst du ich glaube schon der
polarisiert der wird auch ordentlich
aber es habe ich glaube dass sie echt
sind halbe million ja schon halbe
million ja doch doch eine million ist
nicht unrealistisch
lecker pizza ihr könnt ihr alles weg
essen sorgt man die kamera
bis dann daran